it's time to babble the [ __ ] and live
from the Jon Lovitz aah gasps Peter it's
Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
and [ __ ] realize those gonna be
coming to work with [ __ ] carrot top
tonight then it is Saturday night in
Hollywood
so let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin
Smith I want you to tell them your
secret identity
no what brings you here Batman I imagine
there's crime elsewhere but well I've
retired for eight years so I thought I'd
get into podcasting I'm not the pod
caster you need
I'm the podcaster you deserve
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
on a night I get it did you're yelling
you're jealous because I show up every
week wearing the costume and you're like
I want to wear a costume had you told me
I would have worn my bangerra I'm
betting like I always think like I
always think I have a Bane quote at the
ready and then immediately that file
drawer opens and dust comes out perhaps
he's wondering why you would shoot the
man before throwing about the plane now
you go where's Rachel Rachel
where's Rachel sorry it was the last
film what's with the costume you know
your Park admitted now don't take off
your mask oh [ __ ] I guess it doesn't
surprise
it doesn't take Joe gordon-levitt to
figure out who you are
ladies and gentlemen surround everybody
Thank You Ralph of course is celebrating
in the Batman Batman yes of spirit
because you all walked away with tickets
tonight am I correct that's right
everybody here gets a ticket to Batman
live which opens up on September the
27th at Staples Center here in Los
Angeles Kevin and I will be there that
night too let's check it out yes it's a
big stage show if anyone hasn't looked
in online you can pop on YouTube look at
a trailer it's it's basically the Batman
live show you would love to see if you
were caught with a fan all the Dolans
are up on stage Batman and Robin are
there the cars are on stage it's like a
big stunt spectacular like right up here
at Universal they do Waterworld you know
the presentation times that by 8:00 make
it way better and that's what you're
looking at and this one is a story
unlike Waterworld
this is actual it's like a stage play
with pyrotechnic there is actually
written by some common people so that's
cool that's cool we'll see opening night
at Staples Center we like to thank Wendy
and the people at golden voice thank you
very much guys they came to us and they
said we know you guys are big Batman
fans you want to go to Batman Lobby I
said already have tickets and they say
what about the people come your pocket
to me they'd like to go and I go you
know we get like 300 people not enough
for nothing but they're like that's all
we could do that and they hooked us up
with tickets for everybody tonight so
damn awesome as predicted last week this
show we knew would sell out the moment
we mentioned that you'd also get a free
Batman ticket and it's sold that on
Tuesday so yeah it's pretty damn cool
who they love more yeah normally like we
get to about Friday Saturday night text
each other like hey the show was sold
out
yeah and this week it was Tuesday and I
was like we're geniuses
and then he type back wasn't us Mac man
Batman so thanks everybody came out
either for us or for the pre Batman
tickets but this is the second time I
sat next to Batman today I was just at
Stan Lee
a lot of people went from here in the
room I came here down at the Los Angeles
Convention Center they did the Kamikaze
Stan Lee kamikaze it was pretty damn
fantastic it looks like that could
become the permanent Los Angeles comic
book convention they're shooting for I
know the setups impressive they handled
it well not and I went down there to do
an episode of this podcast I do called
fat man on Batman and I was going to
interview first it was gonna be all
three Adam West Burt Ward and Julie
Newmar but the room itself was kind of
said it wasn't conducive for three
people it was really just one-on-one so
it wind up just being me and an Adam
West fat man on Batman oh no you didn't
get on him did you all right was so many
times I did this so he's 83 for God's
sake he's [ __ ] I'll tell you man
dude looks [ __ ] good 483 any sharpest
attacks very [ __ ] sharp I mean like
whatever the mine but this dude's body
like you know 83 year olds generally
don't look between him and Stanley did I
look at these two dudes like Stanley is
[ __ ] 90 like that I look at both of
these two dudes I was like both of these
dudes could whip my ass in a fight yeah
and I'm not even saying that no you're
Beria thought no seriously
those dudes one punch I think take it
out buh buh well it's Batman and
spider-man pretty much right hey
spider-man's dad yeah exactly
how did the interview go Chum your voice
is so much like his the periodical I was
like tell me Ralph you're setting up her
[ __ ] totally man I was just like how
big is Liam Neeson sorry well Kevin I'll
have you know not as big as mine I did
rock him with a bat bowl you went we
were in a big room and there were kids
around so I didn't feel like I could
kind of curse as much as I do not a lot
of rusty sheriff's badges no but I did
get an opportunity for a well-placed to
slide down your bat-pole Joe good man he
laughed at that too so that was kind of
sweet but if you uh if you if you're
hearing this you probably missed the con
put it down in your calendars for next
year it's definitely a comic-con worth
of 10 and it's got Stan Lee's name
attached to it Elvira Sandra Peterson
she's involved in as well it was really
cool I like the concept much and that
episode fat man I'm Batman will go up
this week it was tough because it was we
were in like normally go to a con and
you got closed off room and stuff
we were on the con floor so at first it
was an adjustment period we're like oh
[ __ ] the show is the show you know it's
everybody here on the floor and once we
sat down started talking though went
right into the people [ __ ] love that
guy do as much as I did because I opened
up with like how much like the dude
meant to me and I said look man like
when you're you're the some talk we're
all the sum total of all our experiences
in life but who we want to be in life is
the sum total of all the heroes that we
have the people we look up to we take
little bits and pieces from them we want
to be like these cats right I said my
first hero was
man and my first Batman was Adam West I
was like in this character probably
largely responsible for my moral
barometer man I said a lot of people be
like what about your parents there's
like wealth my parents were killed in
Crime Alley it would have worked out
that's true I said but I'm sparing that
I got my morals from from this this year
Batman ladies jump give it up for Adam
West he came out [ __ ] it brought the
house down man like people love hearing
people reply and I gave my propers about
and Family Guy and stuff like that talks
about that and a bunch of everything I
think I'll Ralph did a fantastic
interview right here with Adam West like
not too long ago about a year ago Airy
February you could hear it if you go to
the smart cast site there's still a link
for an evening with Adam West or you go
to the band campsite and let's do it but
Ralph did what two hours yeah this whole
life and career from the top to bottom
so yeah I didn't have that kind of space
on the stage or time to do it as well
and it was so loud I felt like I told
him I said please coming Mouse we'll do
a more intimate episode and he looked at
me and funny on end today yeah I was
like not in that Ralph Garman way how
dare you sir but it was awesome I mean
like you know I'm [ __ ] 42 and I've
done some [ __ ] and live message [ __ ]
people and whatnot but that dude was one
of the first people that I looked up to
that wasn't from my world when you meet
your boyhood heroes it's a whole
different thing than when you meet
somebody in the in the show
five-year-old and me was so happy and I
felt like he'd maybe come out and I'd
become thin finally but you know just
stayed in there just stayed in there
happy and wanted ice cream I got batter
and [ __ ] you five-year-old nasai punches
my gut Adam West was looking at me weird
but it was it was really really cool man
it was nice to sit down with them and we
talked about you questions my name came
up Utah absolutely so excited as did the
term legal orders
I forget what that thing is where they
make his stand restraining order see the
show is at 8 o'clock this week and right
that [ __ ] with my hole smoking skip
yeah it's not as stoned if you'd like to
be drunk as I'd like to be it's very
strange well I'm in a weird place
because I'm normally like I'm this is my
we and then I show up two hours later
I'm like let's do the [ __ ] show so
right now I'm in we periods so great
it's on to games on your stick so I'm
barely here this evening man I'm still
talking to Adam West let's get to it
shoot it don't say that to him the front
row will be very unhappy it is for those
who are at home or listening and
wondering what the hell's going on we
have moved the show up a little bit to 8
o'clock we say we're gonna try for
primetime now cuz we use to be a late
night show here - love it yeah my whole
lives we've been at 10 o'clock show and
suddenly you're like let's try for
primetime right because we fear people
want to have dinner beforehand or go out
afterwards whatever it's like right in
the middle of date night on Saturday
make it a little bit more accessible to
people we'll see how that works I know
but 10 o'clock is like twin peaks' cool
8 o'clock we're like old male no circle
man don't knock Kirk we made a lot of
[ __ ] money in the last good point but
yeah for the time being we'll try out 8
o'clock feels ok I like it so far yeah
we weren't talking to you we're
interested in each other come on
oh gosh share a quick story with you
then [ __ ] sake well we'll be here at
10 o'clock anyway folk so it doesn't
really matter
[Applause]
we have a lot of show there's another
act coming on at 10:00 you know just
[ __ ] you there are some dancing dogs
coming at 10 o'clock or something
so America's Got Talent is up next I'm
not think I'm at the con today and you
know when you get there you get in the
back door and they bring into this
little waiting room and then boom you're
off on stage right so I kind of went
through the waiting room looked any free
cool snacks nothing that I was into then
headed toward this stay that's the best
part of the job is like you go plays you
like Chips Ahoy yeah I don't have these
at my house so I passed through the room
and there are a few people in there and
I don't make eye contact and [ __ ] cuz
I'm always afraid I'll make eye contact
and I'll be like okay so I just I tend
to look up or around or whatever I don't
bump into people I got a pretty good
sense of like where I'm going even
though I'm never looking straight ahead
so I went through the room went onstage
did my thing with Adam West we left and
[ __ ] Megan Megan who's my right arm and
life money my assistant I want to say
system oh really she's like the puppet
master Megan was in the waiting room for
me because she don't go watch the show
she's like I've heard this fat ass say
everything and like if I hear one more
time where the pucks going I'll kill
myself so she's sitting in that little
green room thing and so she was able to
relate a [ __ ] story she told me the
stories like you're [ __ ] lying she's
like I swear has happened it's all right
man here's the [ __ ] story
I come through that room real quick and
[ __ ] remember all I did when I went
through there where's the snacks right
Thanks [ __ ] and then I left right she
said there were two chicks in there that
was just like oh my god did you see
Kevin Smith he's so hot the other chick
goes I'd [ __ ] them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let me get this straight
[Laughter]
leave it alone dude it's a beautiful
story man
don't debunk it don't don't get also
your assistant who you pay to keep you
happy told you they were two women who
just happened to be in the room who talk
about how hot you were and how they
would [ __ ] you you know when you put it
like that it sounds species no no I
believe it really did these women happen
to leave before you went back into that
room was it just I don't know I heard
they were from Canada yeah well
congratulations
absolutely it's possible I didn't
believe it for a while though I was just
like come on she's like known as a come
on over here [ __ ] like that and that's
the problem I never hear [ __ ] like that
I'm hearing it from her [ __ ] 30
minutes later [ __ ] I would have been
nice to hear in the room cuz I would
have been like I got a real liberal wife
come home with ya uh-huh good luck then
I got a call from Jen the next night
help me bury the body well
congratulations
thank you next time you go to one of
those rooms just step in and say who
wants to [ __ ] me now what you'll hear it
your song my favorite part of the story
though is I was looking at my worst we
were driving in the heat and [ __ ] I had
to race to get there on time so I'm
sweating right when I come in the door
like I'm my mouth ain't closed so
looking at [ __ ] is still some to
clueless [ __ ] like I'd [ __ ] him
makes me feel good about life all right
all right you're a good mood I like that
I'm gonna go home tell my wife of that
man and she'll be that I'm sure that
I'll [ __ ] play well yeah you should
look out and be jealous there are ladies
who would [ __ ] slam
or should like do it go ahead whatever
get away from me Harley can you let that
Ian let's kick off the show with some
shoutouts Kevin Brown sir get your [ __ ]
out
[Applause]
too bad the girls didn't see that in the
waiting room maybe that's why the ladies
like me yeah maybe I would so bring him
home to [ __ ] my boyfriend she was
missing legs have got a chubby cuckold
and [ __ ]
chubby cuckold that's my favorite Ben
and Jerry's Lavery name of my bed in
high school are Adam Lee Brik Johnson
and Laura here right am I saying that
name correct Adam Adam Lee Brik Johnson
yes I'm saying correctly did your did
your forefathers fight in the war I'm
wondering its language you Jewish
[Applause]
that's what you get for Downton that I
could get some [ __ ] man did your
forefathers run during the war good for
them there was been fast people all it
was missing was you jerk I'm Jewish you
jerk
Adam rides my fiancee Laura and I got
engaged in May at the Renaissance Fair
on my birthday and I attended to bring
her to Babylon to celebrate not long
after that however in early June she was
diagnosed with ovarian cancer and had to
have surgery now several months later
she had a successful surgery she's doing
very well through her chemotherapy
session congratulations is my favorite
kind of news I was wondering if edwin
could congratulations on being engaged
and tell her how thankful I am that
she's still with me and be with me for
many years to come ah oh my goodness
absolutely I could say something
congratulations on beating cancer of
your lady parts what you cool lady part
like you think I said but you said lady
balls which I was like it's not what you
call ovaries honey we're bout your lady
balls what's so happy you're healthy
again and congratulations on Adams
ancestors running fast from the Nazi
[Applause]
well they cover all my bases
our Frankie and Francesca here tonight
it's adorable you guys a couple or a
brother and a sister they're a couple
you're a couple husband and wife what is
it Frankie and Francesca good enough to
change your [ __ ] monograms for
Oliveri man
it's amazing all thats what you look for
in on me somebody to keep your towels
safe
mine goes to monograms yeah man I'm
married I've mocked Kevin's
methanogenesis wall bug we'd have to
change [ __ ] oh nice I still got [ __ ]
from her previous relationship she said
my name is Frankie my wife and I will be
attending the show on Saturday be the
second time seeing you and Kevin the
first time being at the Smaug castle wow
man old Hollywood babble-on episode 8
[ __ ] former's that was a good one
96 97 now serving I was hoping you'd
give her a shout-out as Adam West
letting her know that she is my
everything my soul mate and that her
joining a roller derby league makes her
the most badass wife in the world what's
your name what's your name on the rink
iron breezer-freezer that would be a
weak-ass roller plate man I'm the iron
please there I just breezed by you you
don't even notice me I'm like a fresh
summer breeze but it's got iron up front
man so I can't like just breeze by it's
just like I'm the arm breeze excuse me
iron bruiser alright Adam West
congratulating on your roller derby
success this is my life this is what I
do this is how I spend my Saturday is
what you get at the eight o'clock show
man ten o'clock [ __ ] like this don't
happen tall [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ]
shots yeah go leather Cheerios and rusty
wagon wheel
Franchesca congratulations on being a
badass on wheels
quickly old chump to the iron brews
mobile nothing a man finds sexier than a
woman who can beat up another woman
while on roller skates and
congratulations on keeping your bath
towels the same with your monograms you
sound more Adam West than Adam West food
having just sat next to the man I
believe you more than him we start doing
appearances for him our Brian lip go and
Ashley in the house Frank yeah you can't
really raise your hand in the podcast
sir I mention this every week it's very
polite of you and I appreciate you it
was just too cool for school okay yo was
up and I'm surprised you're not louder
sir after I read your email because he
says my girlfriend Ashley and I are from
Philadelphia Philadelphia Pennsylvania
my hometown who dares to boo
Philadelphia you're the wrong [ __ ]
theater son thank you James pretty sure
it was Apollo Creed yeah whoo you
mention the regular one little fight the
foil [ __ ] the big point you know I said
Apollo Creed I know I don't do it by
Lucroy we recently moved here after
graduating from Temple University go
owls is that their team is the a yeah
[Laughter]
you're gonna hurt your neck one day
because you know I would play football
on the field get six points for three
points do you read let's do trick for
the trick bag you what down low he does
that you're adding to it man what your
impression is growing
soon you'll be unstoppable man Yoda of
doing Bill Cosby this is our first time
seeing Babylon you guys moved here right
from Philly you're in town now could you
wish her a happy birthday in your Al
Pacino voice because she's got a great
ass he writes she's my Vicky bail my
mary-jane my Lois Lane
so she's a fictional character you
masturbate to sir or she's too stupid to
figure out who you really are
keep up the good work Brian lip go Los
Angeles California
come on with the cheese sticks soft
pretzels
come on now Liberty Bell oh I'm post a
happy birthday happy birthday Ashley or
should I call you Ashley
cuz you got a great ass
there you go well I have a bonus I have
a bonus for you guys I forgot to mention
this email came shortly after yours my
name is John from Philadelphia my best
friend from college Brian is in the
audience tonight with his girlfriend
Ashley celebrating her birthday
Brian moved out from Philly after
college and I stayed in Philly so
unfortunately I never met Ashley but I
wanted to give her a present as well
Brian somehow acquired the nickname butt
[ __ ] Brian in college
[Laughter]
brian is there anything you'd like to
tell us man I hope it was an ironic name
it's John right by any chance that was
your nickname in college yeah at least
you're honest I thought it was only
fitting that John Travolta convinced
clients haha that it wouldn't be weird
to let Ashley strap one on for one night
and penetrate his poopy pork pipe as a
special birthday treat to her you're
welcome Ashley enjoy my friends anal
virginity I hope to meet you soon thanks
guys and go flyers John from
Philadelphia so there's your buddy so
weird you name was bug bug Brian
eCollege what when my name was bud [ __ ]
Brian in college here's more of a
command move my roommates name was Brian
so weird well welcome to Los Angeles in
Philadelphia if you need to find a good
cheesesteak ask me I'll tell you what
after the show all right and as we say
well here in California welcome to Los
Angeles put a dick in your mouth or in
butt but Brian's case take that dick out
of your mouth we also get emails from
all around the world every show
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions
hello babblers my name is John Anderson
although the name might pass me as an
American I'm in fact Swedish well mr.
Anderson
the well-respected Swedish newspaper
Dagens netter had a headline on its
website that immediately caught my
attention now I got this from several
sources from our fans in Sweden so I
know it's true because I looked it up
and I hit Google Translate and I read
the article okay here was the headline I
[ __ ] you not this was in like the New
York Times of Sweden okay
well hung Hollywood heroes searching for
God yes you guessed it the DN had an
exclusive interview with Liam Neeson the
reporter said in the article again this
is true I looked it up Neeson had never
been involved in these scandals this is
the quote from the article and it
translated so it sounds a little honky
in in the translated English but you'll
get the gist of it Neeson is deemed mr.
nice guy who never created scandalous
headlines and spawned some rumors the
most persistent rumor Neeson is that he
is the most well hung male in Hollywood
at least if you believe Kevin Smith and
Ralph Garman
podcast
that created a national movement with
people trying to outdo each other by
finding humorous parables on the theme
how big is Liam Neeson's [ __ ] we've gone
international
we've gone Internet community my
favorite part of the article is this
next line but Neeson's genitals seem
still not large enough to overshadow his
image as a devoted family father fly
fisherman and voracious reader big
reader is apparently reading all these
ancient books going how do I shrink this
[ __ ] well thank you John for sending
me that link and if you look in the
article the reporter mentioned that in
the article how random is that it's just
a shame that since it's in Swedish it's
not gonna get back to him like boobs in
an Irish newspaper he might open it up
be like who
but Swedish doubt I doubt he's gonna run
the article through a google translator
but he must have pressed people or
something to follow this stuff right
Garmin every week they talk about your
dick that would freak me out if somebody
just came up to me and they're like
listen to this and they played like a
two-hour compilation bucket to strangers
going like Kevin Smith's [ __ ] is so
little and everyone like haha this next
email is from the UK my name is
Giancarlo kamatari I'm an Indian an
Italian name - South African living in
England ok diplomatic immunity it
literally is yeah last week ralph
mentioned about a Philadelphian
superhero named gar man and together
with the details about ralph that sprung
for that put this image in my head and i
had to draw it i hope i didn't draw them
too small rights claudio this is what he
drew and sent in this is me as a
superhero feel the power of my balls and
it's me as a superhero swinging two
massive balls that's my superpower
that's art imitating life right up there
is thank you so much for that the next
email my name is Wayne I live in
Newfoundland Canada I was going eh I
thought Newfoundland was its own place
is that Canada really yeah yeah there's
like an uncle in which is separate no no
it's it's own it's in the Maritimes
innit Atlantic Atlantic Canada Eastern
you know way Eastern Ken I used to think
Toronto was the end of Canada too and
people like your [ __ ] mind what about
[ __ ] Montreal what about [ __ ] the
maritime so hey Maritimes that sounded
cool to make so I was like do mermaids
live there now apparently not no
Wainwright's my wife and my wife Tia and
I make a point to listen to every
Babylon together she's a huge fan of the
podcast this past june we got married
being the fan that she is she asked me
to email you guys and get marriage
advice as we start a new life together
well I forgot and I forgot to do it the
next week and so on and so on and now we
got married in June and it's September
and for the past three months whenever
we listen to the show it gets to the
email portion she turns to me and says
you never did email them did you and I
quickly come up with an excuse and hope
she moves on I'm truly sorry for putting
this off for so long her birthday is
Tuesday and I was hoping Kevin in his
sexy
Kevin voice could wish her a happy
birthday and tell her I'm sorry for the
three-month delay for emailing you guys
thanks a lot Wayne what's her name her
name is Tia ATM how'd you like a back
rub that's how I start to wane some good
not yourself well I'm just getting her
in the mood oh okay I'm not gonna be
there so once she gets all moist and
[ __ ] you got to turn to this [ __ ]
loser and a bigger I'm helping out so
stand back all right
just cuz it's not done Allah al pacino
don't mean it ain't fun I'm sorry I
didn't realize this is the new you after
two two anonymous women said they wanted
to [ __ ] you this is the new sexually
aggressive Kevin I apologize
Oh TIA
how dare you sir t idea
lay down me rub your back oh [ __ ] my
hands on your [ __ ] oh I meet you
oh we're [ __ ] oh we're done that's
just like what sex is you've had the
whole Kevin Smith experience to you well
there you go Wayne and everything should
be fine at home now
this next email comes from Pam I know
you get a lot of requests for emails and
I hope you'll consider this even though
there's nothing about rusty wagon wheels
or come sorry we couldn't possibly know
I have to because this is this is this
is kind of an important one this wooden
this one touched me my friend and
co-worker Dustin has two big events
coming up his last chemo treatment and
his 39th birthday he downloads Hollywood
babble-on to listen to during his chemo
treatments you guys gave him a lot of
laughs and we're a great distraction to
the depressing room he was in he got the
good news the other day that his
lymphoma tumors are dead so he will be
celebrating a big birthday coming up all
his friends are looking forward to
having the drinking buddy back Dustin
will be listening to the September 15th
podcast while he's enduring his last
chemotherapy treatment and probably
wearing the HBO shirt I got for him
congratulations sir
well done give that penis of my [ __ ]
sandwich it [ __ ] like that that makes me
late I'm not wasting my Saturday nights
here getting drunk you know it's true
man you're making somebody's life just a
little bit better with your bone in it
although that's our that's our second
cancer email though so far tonight
that's true I think we might give people
cancer that's my fear that's my fear
people listen to as they're getting
cancer and then they're getting cured
which is good news but I told Matt we're
giving them cancer
we need Christian Bale to come along and
take away their cancer
we're essentially like a pack of
cigarettes man sweetheart we give people
happiness in cancer one thing he said
you're a [ __ ] I thought he said I think
he said air puffs air [ __ ] is that what
you said
you're pure [ __ ] oh your [ __ ] that's
what I'm I didn't know what air [ __ ]
meant either when you said it as if that
was explanation I was like first I
thought air [ __ ] like like billet ever
play the air guitar [ __ ]
you and me we could have a thing where
and say we do air guitar we do air [ __ ]
were like we're instituting that anytime
we have a joke that we both like I
thought air [ __ ] was maybe Michael
Jordan's new line of underwear for women
just do it the new nike air [ __ ] just
[ __ ] it
Rolfing kept my name is Ben I live in
shitty Alabama is that very sick Alabama
it's time for a long-distance dedication
oh that means we need some sad ho music
and you crank me up some sad ho music
Sara
DJ Jam master James Jimmy Jim Jim James
I've been a fan since the first episode
so when I started dating my then
girlfriend Ashley I had to pop her HBO
cherry it quickly became her favorite
oral pleasure sadly after over a year of
dating think didn't work out she took it
really hard and though we're not
together I still care about her deeply
recently she tweeted that all she wanted
in the world was an HBO t-shirt and a
song from David Bowie I'm single now so
I'm not buying her [ __ ]
but emails are free I know it would mean
the world to her if you would sing to
her as David Bowie it would mean the
world to me
if you would tell her in song that I
don't want to get back together but we
can still totally [ __ ] listener fan well
I think I could convey that message in
the style of David Bowie
he won't date you but he'll [ __ ] you
he won't date you feel free to take back
Venus but he won't take you on a date he
loved a cheese [ __ ] [ __ ] you friends
with benefits all
not interested in going up with you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you rotate you
[ __ ] are you the most exercise I get all
week yesterday hey it's a creepy clown
time we got an email by creepy clown
time I'm glad someone is putting the
creepy back in creepy clown time because
you know quick reset the reason I'll
start is because I started doing this
impression of a clown a deadly murderous
clown who was putting on his white face
makeup while slowly singing the creepy
clown song and Kevin would get creeped
out by and then we started adding voices
to people suggest oh do it as this wacky
character do it as this wacky character
and it got funny and he got the fun and
we did Bill Cosby in Louie Armstrong it
went away from the scares it was kind of
like the entire Nightmare on Elm Street
franchise exactly it was [ __ ] chilling
and deadly serious about like a [ __ ]
child molester from hell with knives on
his fingers and then by the end he had
babies yeah it was like Freddy babies
and [ __ ] like yeah he was buddies with
Jason so we lightened up you're taking
it back to the creek well Chris Chris
from Layton Utah taking it back to the
creek I'm glad he's putting some
weirdness back into this bit gentlemen
term used loosely your rights may be
Kevin's fear of creepy clowns may be
started again by adding a little more
creepy to it perhaps Ralph could do the
clown as professor Stephen Hawking
a murderous clown in a wheelchair oh
that's hard yeah
if Kevin wants to he can play the
dutiful nurse and apply some makeup for
Steve he really can't put on his makeup
now that I think about it oh that's hard
it's very dark and it's very creepy and
I'm looking forward to it so this this
week's creepy clown is professor Stephen
Hawking that that that that that that
that's the creepiest thing we've done in
a while I like it every week we say
goodbye to some people in show business
who had wonderful careers wonderfully
long lives as Kevin would say deserve a
big bucket of wind we say goodbye to
them with the Tinseltown steps and now
another edition of
they will be missed they can hear that
in the grave first up is a woman named
Dorothy McGuire now you may not know the
name she died at 84 this week she was
part of a pop music sensation called the
McGuire sisters back in the 50s if you
ever see a movie about the 50s they
always throw in some McGuire sisters
music because they were one of the
biggest acts in the world sort of pre
rock and roll in terms of that sweet pop
sound that was very popular in the mid
50s before Elvis changed everything they
were known for Smash Hits I mean they
had like it doesn't dunk number-one hits
throughout their career sugar time
remember that song sugar in the evening
sugar in the morning sugar at suppertime
know what else I hate old-timey songs do
you really oh god I hate [ __ ] these
old-timey singing I mean I'm sad she
died no you're not I'm gonna well you're
glad she's dead I remember I have to sit
there with my grandmother and watch old
timey singers together and I guess they
were young at one point but but time I
watch them unlike Lawrence well there'd
be three of them they look like three of
your grandmother that's what they did
though these three sisters would get
together in harmony but the harmonies
were amazing yeah but their harmonizing
about like [ __ ] sugar [ __ ] that man
sing I'm a little
[Laughter]
they're always chicks always you'd be
excited there's no point in singing
about something you're knee-deep in 24/7
man so as a kid you know you'd want to
hear him sing about [ __ ] like sing about
the devil but no they sang about [ __ ]
like sugar is another one of their hits
you'll hate it because you don't like
old-time music you you're much better
when you're stoned at ten o'clock you're
much more mellow
by the McGuire's is called sincerely
[Music]
Oh
like we're at the prom somebody's gonna
get shot we're gonna want if it's
Shawshank taken from the mirror about to
kill somebody this is a song from my
parents Dorothy McGuire passed away at
84 these [ __ ] it'll win her sisters by
the way are still alive
were they still like doing it like
singing with the three of them were
performing in the mid-2000s they were
still touring really good but now now
they're now they won't be touring so
much yeah yeah Kevin's glad she's dead
this one I saw when this guy died I knew
you'd be you'd be interested Ron Taylor
passed away at the age of 78 years old
you may not know the name unless you're
an Australian because he was sort of
famous in his home country for being a
marine conservationist he was a big
proponent of saving the great white
shark only because he used to be a
champion spear fisherman that's right he
tells this wonderful story about one day
being underwater and having this
epiphany where he's like I come down
here into their world and stab them and
kill them and stuff he's like I don't
want to do it anymore
went up to the surface he didn't even
weigh in his fish or anything he was
done from that moment forward it was
about conserving it was about getting up
close there's a wonderful quote about
him where they said he hunted the great
white - with a camera yeah now this is
the guy him and his wife Valerie if you
remotely like jaws at all and you've
ever watched any behind-the-scenes I
read the jaws log or you know anything
about the making of these two cats were
hand tapped by Spielberg back in the day
to shoot some real great white shark
footage if you watched jaws of course
most the time when you see Bruce if you
see Bruce the shark you know he's a big
fake rubber shark and [ __ ] when Richard
Dreyfuss goes down in the caves there
are a few shots up it
let me get this snake cage goes in the
water you go in the water sharks in the
water farewell and I do brave Spanish
lady your dear legless big doer legs
that flick in when you look at the
footage of what looks like clearly real
great walk what great white shark
footage Ron and tower of Ron and Valerie
Taylor shot it what they did was find a
smaller cage put a smaller actor in it
to make the shark look as big as he was
supposed to be in the movie right so
this was at a time before like you know
they could ISDN the footage and
Spielberg can't even watch it happening
perhaps shooting it so he was like he
sent a call to these guys shoot some
footage man this is what we're going for
go for this with the cage and other
sharks and then like as toward the end
of the show he saw the footage and there
were some usable shots that actually
wound up in the movie so it's pretty
high iconic footage and he said like he
felt like they spent the rest of their
lives making it up to the great white
shark because part of his footage went
into the movie that completely [ __ ]
demonized great white sharks right so he
spent most of his life photographing
them and conserving them kind of make up
for that really incredible life and I
pointed out in SModcast last week
this dude by all rights you spends much
time in water around great white sharks
should have gotten killed by one of
those [ __ ] yeah didn't beat the odds
you know what I'm saying like he died of
what natural causes yeah doesn't say
what he did it's [ __ ] amazing oh wait
it says he got cancer listened to a
podcast [ __ ] we lost one
[Music]
my favorite story is he built this chain
mail shark zoo this would be shark
repellant he built it
he made that the original shark suit
yeah and it turned out it was too small
for him so he put it on his wife and he
sent her in the water to test it that's
that's a husband right there he didn't
care for her at all and lastly you know
I love character actors I talk about it
every week invariably one of them passes
and I talk about his career and how much
I loved his work this was another guy
Lance Legault was his name you don't
know his name but you probably know his
face he was hit like a 50-year career
one of these guys who just worked
forever started out in the business as a
stunt double for Elvis Presley in the
Elvis movies he did Elvis his double
work in Viva Las Vegas and kissing
cousins a couple other films then he
moved on to acting for himself but he
always played military guys for some
reason he was every military guy on
every TV show in the 70s and 80s you
ever seen that you've seen stripes right
yeah he was Colonel glass in in stripes
he was in Rockford Files Battlestar
Galactica magnum p.i just every show in
the 70s days you would see his face pop
up but he's best known for his role in
the a-team where he played colonel
Roderick Decker the guy who was always
hunting down the a-team you remember
this guy here's a little piece of video
if you don't remember Colonel Decker
from the a-team everybody heard the
reports from now on these guys because
they're fast sharp and unorthodox a way
to catch them in like this is to play by
their rules which means there are none
there are none that dude is like very
much but this segment of the show is all
about he is literally the glue that held
together 30 40 50 years of TV and movies
like no one ever knew his name and no
one knows that you see him and you're
like I know that [ __ ] guy nobody's
dead we can't appreciate it we give him
a tribute yeah so that's nice for that
guy every once in a while we like to
talk about celebrities who are able to
get out of the way their own egos do
something for someone else other than
themselves it's not it's not that often
that that happens so when it does we
like to celebrate it with the Hollywood
helpers
what is your fascination with your own
nipples they're not they're big enough
but not big enough to reach you know who
should get implants is what you should
do to Hollywood helpers this week first
is Julia Roberts
apparently the vein in her far had
jumped off her body and saved the life
this week I kid Julia we're close she
apparently lives in Malibu she has a
home in Malibu and she has organic
produce brought to her home on a regular
basis infants and virgins as well to be
sacrificed on an altar Liberty while she
wears a goat head and wields a Crim the
banner that's the life and eats the
child in fact she lives for another
hundred years so you know it's been
brutally hot here in Southern California
so she ordered her organic produce the
guy shows up at her door and he's just
dripping sweat it's like it's like Kevin
Smith's sweat I mean this guy's this guy
is sweating how do you know wasn't Kevin
Smith delivery it's true maybe you're
taking extra work oh so she said wow you
look sweaty oh no not that good oh
because that she helped him out of his
comm no
he explained that the air-conditioning
in his car had gone out he had no
air-conditioning his car
dudes driving around delivering produce
with no air in his car okay so she asked
him what does it cost to get your air
fix and he said they told me about five
hundred bucks so she cut says hold on a
second
comes back with five hundred dollars
cash and gives it the delivery guy so
he'd get his air conditioning then she
blew him but she wouldn't kiss him
that's right not until they fall in love
that's right not till he climbed a
ladder to get her out of a window he
came back and [ __ ] to show off his air
conditioner all fix brought her into the
car she was looking at the vent she went
to touch and he closed him real quick
that's an inside joke I just watched it
recently our second Hollywood helper
this week is Billy Campbell you may know
him as Rocketeer that's right the
Rockets here from the 1991 classic
superhero movie the Rockets here he's an
actual hero this week and I mean this is
no [ __ ] this is no give you five
hundred dollars to get your air
conditioner fixed this is some serious
life saving but yeah man you just give
it and take it away you're like Julia
Roberts everybody with like a nice thing
and then I hit you with the life-saving
the real deal Billy was sailing his
brand-new schooner from Nova Scotia to
Rhode Island recently
[Laughter]
sir the microphone was travelling to my
lips cuz I was like I'm gonna say
sailboat and he beat me to it small rats
joke alright moving on I gotta watch
that movie one of these days I think
I've heard it's very good I think that's
Ben Affleck in the audience somebody
only someone from our ads remember that
well done sir
so he's a sailing along and he notices
an overturned vessel floating in
Buzzards Bay the [ __ ] out here's a Ben
Gardner's boat no Buzzards Bay Maine and
he he says look at that wreckage over
there I should cruise over there and see
what's going on he finds three men
hanging onto a piece of wood for dear
life
dear God indeed madam please tell me one
of them was Leonardo DiCaprio yeah he
was like Rose you [ __ ] why did you just
boom over on the board you [ __ ] he
immediately ordered his crew to pluck
the men out of the water and bring them
aboard here's the thing the capsized
boats had no emergency lights the men
had no way to signal for help if he
hadn't stopped
no one ever would have found them they
were [ __ ] they were seriously [ __ ]
they were treated for hypothermia
otherwise they said they were okay when
he finally pulled him out of the water
and Julia Roberts blew them all so the
story has a happy ending but he
literally saved three lives jetpack on
it's a Fermi just pulled about the water
like should we get him out of the wars
like no I need my costume we go go back
to land
gotta get my rocky give me your gum my
rescue these guys thank you so much
every once in a while every once in a
while every [ __ ] week you take a look
at a movie or TV show that features a
glaring error that somebody should have
caught at some point while they were
editing the film while there was
marketing the film before the people saw
it they should have said that [ __ ] that
should not be this week [ __ ] that should
not be goes to show you sometimes there
can be a glaring error in the film but
the performance is so good the people
involved say [ __ ] it just let it ride
and that's what happened that's what
must have happened in this film and I'll
tell you something this is one of my
favorite films I've seen this a bunch of
times I never noticed this glaring
mistake until somebody pointed it out to
me okay
the movie is Boogie Nights you guys like
Boogie Nights William H Macy just a god
to me just it one of the best plays
little bill on the film yes and in the
film he plays the husband to a porn star
nina hartley played by nina hartley in
the film who's constantly [ __ ] other
guys while he's around he's the ultimate
cuckold and he's sort of a melee melee
guy and he just takes it and in the film
there's a scene where there's a big
party at Burt Reynolds house and she is
taking it in the poop chute from some
guy in the driveway of the house and
people are surrounding them watching
them and she says go away and he just
like he just kind of walks away and
Ricky J comes up to him starts talking
about the production of the film she is
taking it in the ass in the scene listen
to what William hpc says to Ricky J
while they're having a conversation it's
a major [ __ ] error but it's William H
Macy so I think every said oh [ __ ] it
let's just put it in the movie anyway
here's a scene from Boogie Nights Kurt
no hey God [ __ ] you gotta go somewhere
so heavy what the [ __ ] is only the
photography the film we're talking about
are you giving me [ __ ] Kurt No
my [ __ ] wife has an ass inner [ __ ] in
the driveway Kurt alright I'm sorry if
my folks are not a limpet ography of the
film was shooting tomorrow okay yeah all
right yeah he says my [ __ ] wife has
an ass in her [ __ ] and I get the sense
somebody said hey Paul bill just said
that she's got an ass in her [ __ ] and
he's like no let it go it's good let it
go I remember that man like I remember
seeing that movie maybe not the first
time but one of the viewings on DVD and
I was like huh
maybe that's slang or every week also we
like to take a look at some big-time
movie stars who turn in some small-time
performances it's the exquisite acting
[Music]
[Music]
this week I feel like it's a cheat when
we do this but I can't help myself
this week's star is Nicolas Cage and I
know just show scene after scene after
scene but this one was sent to me by a
gentleman named spider-man manm and he
claims that is his legal name and he
says if we ever do the show in Minnesota
he'll bring his driver's license to
prove it and I said that's not enough
reason to go to [ __ ] Minnesota I kid
I love Minnesota
I've never been it's probably wonderful
is the Canada of America it's amazing
well now that you've sold it that way
that's where people go to dice the dress
the movie is ghost riders spirit of
vengeance you may like may have seen
this movie in theaters what were we
thinking
it's Nic Cage talking to a bad guy about
the fact that he's got the Ghost Rider
within him who's dying to get out
because he's a bad person and the Ghost
Rider wants to eat his soul I gave a
better performance explaining it the Nic
Cage does in this scene just now it's a
little bit longer than most exquisite
acting clips rights spider-man but he
says the torture is worth it because if
just period doesn't period stop period
here's a little scene starring Nicolas
Cage as Ghost Rider spirit of vengeance
it's remarkable it's exquisite acting
[Music]
he's scraping at the door he's scraping
at the door okay now you gotta give it
to him and he swings for the [ __ ]
fence and nobody says no to this nobody
ever says like do that how about a twice
[ __ ] Rock want to first base to it
we'll take a double on this one you do
not have to swing for the fence my new
catchphrase I'll be using it all the
time
what is it he's scraping is more of a
scrape protector morbus great protector
e-minor favorite game we were doing it
for some weeks now is when people take
Photoshop and they insert my buddy Kevin
Smith into places he just doesn't belong
the brand-new segment we call Kevin
[Music]
what's cab in this week this week's
theme for what's kept in is Kevin as
little boys
each of these three photo op lecture
tradition each of these photos features
Kevin as a little boy let's start with
one of the classic comedies of all time
the movie airplane here is here's Peter
Graves coming on to Kevin in the cockpit
you ever seen a gladiator movie Kevin
that's from Randall in Winchester
Virginia the next one is from Lewis
Williams from Portsmouth England he sent
in a picture of Kevin as a little boy
it's it's Kevin from home alone
they forgot Kevin on their vacation yeah
but Kevin they're in the real-life home
alone would never be like oh my god I'm
by myself he'd be like oh I woke up this
morning man nobody was up in the house I
was like this is me Tom I tagged a
fleshlight six time oh [ __ ] you it was
amazing
not to depart from our segment here but
I don't know no flashlight yeah I'm not
any good mine no see that this is gonna
be my point
I'm not aficionado with a flashlight
like I know you are so I just have a
question about
maintenance I guess is what I'm asking
for the fleshlight is a receptacle yeah
and so I'm guessing and you said six
you're kidding but six times but that's
what's amazing about this thing dude
like what happens there a reservoir of
some kind yeah oh you could just pack
that thing like a shotgun in a movie how
it just never ends it's always like when
they never reload same [ __ ] but is there
a cleaning procedure that you find
there's a screw top on the bottom that
you just release whatever even saving up
it's like the spit valve on a trumpet or
something thank you very much and it
spits out generations of Smith's and
lastly in Kevin this comes from Josh in
Chattanooga Tennessee this has to do
with last week's show where we talk
about Christian Bale who was able to fly
out a five-year old cancer patient to
Disneyland to have lunch with his family
Josh said he thought this was fair game
since the kids in remission here's a
Christian Bale with little candy brought
to Disney so that is you that's your
make-a-wish hanging out but I'd make him
put on the costume right no you look
like my friend Ralph Garman wears a
costume let's make it thanks for
bringing me this to the to the thing
Batman take your pants off what is this
gonna cure me it's not gonna hurt it's
gonna be very painful for you I know
it's a kid yeah what's wrong I apologize
you're gonna let's take a look at the
week's entertainment news headlines with
a segment we call HBO headlines
[Music]
Google announced this week that they're
adding to their searchable website by
adding a new element called the bacon
number as everybody's on the ship all
you need to do is type any actor's name
and then bacon number after it hit
search and it will tell you how many
degrees of Kevin Bacon they're separated
for and it's also not just an actor you
put yourself in do you put anybody yeah
any name bacon number hit Search and
will tell you how many people removed
from Kevin Bacon you are which is a game
that people have been playing for years
six degrees of Kevin Bacon right and he
never really commented on it recently
though he's opened up a website called
six degrees dot or dorsum which he's
using as a charity thing that's fun for
years people be like six degrees right
he'd be like shut the [ __ ] up man
like it bugged him he didn't like it
that much but now I guess he embraces it
but this is so [ __ ] flattering could
you imagine like they built it into the
Google searches Jody how long he's been
in an entertainment business and how
many films he's done they gave us some
examples here for example Marlon Brando
- he's got a number of - he's two
degrees away from Kevin Bacon okay he
was in The Godfather with Robert Duvall
and Duvall was in the movie with Kevin
Bacon called Jayne Mansfield's car okay
classic Charles Nelson Reilly has a -
how how do you make the connection to
bacon there Riley was with Burt Reynolds
in all dogs go to heaven and Burt
Reynolds and Kevin Bacon were in
starting over together starting over
with me Oh Kleber yes Kevin Bacon was in
that Andy how long he's been acting
Kevin Bacon is like [ __ ] uh what's
that movie man with the portrait where
the do portrait of Dorian Gray
he's Dorian Gray dude he just doesn't
age and he's been around it's he's
slipping it in like a vampire would man
like just every once awhile you're like
oh my god he's in that you're like yeah
I think he doesn't look any older either
true and neither there's his [ __ ]
wife he's married to the closer man the
two of them together are gorgeous and I
think they're like 90 but they bathe in
like milk and virgins blood or something
because they are
they look [ __ ] phenomen they got kids
who are like now coming into their late
teens and 20s the kids look older than
[ __ ] Kevin Bacon and the closer well
that's how they stay young they siphon
the lifeforce off their children no
Lindsay Lohan has it too how she
appeared in her be fully loaded with
Matt Dillon Matt Dillon and Kevin Bacon
appeared in wild things together Snooki
is a three Snooki how she got there she
was in three stooges with Larry David
Larry David and Dianne Wiest were in
Radio days together and we stand bacon
were in Footloose so I thought it would
be only appropriate for us to plug us in
and see if we could least beat Snooki
okay so I put me in first this is this
is me up first I'm a to me and Kevin
Chapman were in two for the money
together with Al Pacino and yet and
McConaughey and Kevin Chapman and bacon
were in Mystic River together so I said
well I beat Snooki let's see if I can
beat Kevin Smith so I popped you in your
two as well you and Neve Campbell were
in scream 3 and then Neve Campbell and
Kevin Baker were in wild things and in
that movie Kevin Bacon was in that game
yes he was and what's your name
that's wait movie that even though
you're an adult and [ __ ] and you have
access to like pornography on the
internet if you're watching it see her
sooner or later your hands like mmm
when they're all in the pool and [ __ ]
I'm not saying you jerk-off but you move
it around and maybe go if it gets hard I
will jerk oh what's going on why we're
talking about Diane she's in the news
this week
why don't you come to your senses
[ __ ] Lindsay Lohan she got a role in
a movie called scary movie 5 look works
work works work and something's got to
keep her in blow it's not free people
[ __ ] trust me it's not free
so she was lucky to get the role in
scary movie 5 but here's the thing New
York Post is reporting she blew off
rehearsals for the movie and all the
meetings with the producers to get ready
for the film and then she missed her
flight to Atlanta to start shooting the
movie alright it's one thing if you like
look I don't [ __ ] rehearse if you
could bring the magic on set a [ __ ] and
she does and then it's another thing to
be like look I don't want to talk to the
producers ahead of time you can
circumvent all these things what you
can't circumvent around the actress
isn't there
you can't shoot ooh see that's what it
turns out to be that's that's one of
those things that will get you kicked
off of a movie they love to shoot film
when it's scheduled to be shot yeah
they're funny that way it's uh it's a
mistake every time somebody gives her a
little [ __ ] break man she just kind
of shits in their mouth now of course
the the actress who is eagerly trying to
knock Lindsay off the top of the
mountain when it comes to [ __ ] train
wrecks amanda Bynes was in the news a
lot this week this is like a four-day
story people so everyone sit down relax
kick your feet up on Sunday night
amanda Bynes from what I like about you
and then the Nick show the show Amanda
she was in a band
well a lot of work she has had her
ticket pulled she's had her license
pulled by the DMV because she's too
outstanding hit-and-runs that have yet
to be adjudicated as we say so you're
allowed to hit a car and just [ __ ] off
no now the authorities frown on that and
that's why they say you have to come to
court and we need to have a discussion
about that in the meanwhile we'd like to
have your driver's license please
so hers is suspended and so she's now
driving on a suspended drivers license
Sunday she was pulled over by cops for
driving at night without her headlights
on that's pretty bad that's bad if you
want to be clean cars have like an
automatic setting now where you don't
even have to turn yes she had to get out
of the car and smash her headlights with
a tire iron in order to not have her
lights on she was you aggressively was
trying not to drive well the cops pulled
her over gave her a verbal warning let
her go on her way they didn't ask for
her license so they didn't know that she
was driving on a suspended license okay
then Tuesday rolls around Tuesdays my
favorite day of the week for Amanda
Bynes because she was driving around
once again on a suspended license while
talking on a pipe I see that grin on
your face Kevin Smith but I'm telling
you this is no way to operate a motor
vehicle here's a shot of Amanda toking
on what looks like a lighter it's a it's
a pipe disguised as a lighter sad image
it looks like one of those 80s PSAs yeah
you know maybe see after-school special
yes
Amanda's alone except this is not a
glass dick this is a looks like a butane
lighter like a Bic lighter no it looks
like the lighter that you push into the
car lighter yeah I saw a picture in the
paper of it yeah you saw a picture get
one of those it looks like that you
replace your cigarette lighter in your
car with it you take that one out you
put this in this one you snap it open
you put a little bit of nug in there and
you can smoke it like that yeah and then
put it away and if a cop pulls you over
they wouldn't be like it's not a [ __ ]
pipe because it's right you saw it in
the TMZ piece yeah but what they also
showed in the TMZ piece is the cup
holder the remnants
she just has like weed laying the [ __ ]
around in her car I am just like
sprinkled around like [ __ ] like this
we'll make it smell better yeah like the
pot Fairy came to her car and just gave
her a dusting I mean that's like a cop
walks past and sees that he could just
wait for you to show up a lot of people
said well the photo she'll be smoking
anything in that pipe how do you know
it's marijuana well look at picture - no
one does this what is she doing I can't
see that's her there in the sunglasses
behind the giant cloud of hot smoke
don't do that with like tobacco or
salvia and then you know what it sold it
for me is picture three of the sequence
where apparently she ended up at Baja
Fresh that's how I knew case closed your
honor she was high cuz she got the
munchies and ended up in the parking lot
of Baja Fresh
justjust mainlining tacos she sets the
movement back so far because the people
are like what happens when the stoners
smoke their mary-jane they eat and not
all of us do that some of us got our
eating done way before we found we all
right and then on Thursday night she was
driving once again the suspended license
in West Hollywood was pulling out of a
parking lot around 10:30 p.m. and tagged
the back of someone else's car and then
drove off without leaving her
information what the [ __ ] like it's
beyond a cry for help like she wants to
get caught at this point this is my
theory a friend of hers is in prison and
she wants to break her out she's
desperately trying to get arrested so
she can go inside she's got the plans to
the prison tattooed all over her body
she's gonna look okay we have to go to
the heating ducts and we can sneak out
and there's gonna be some sort of like
and there's a chopper outside it's like
a rescue mission at this point I'll buy
anything I think she's [ __ ] looking
for Horcruxes of the [ __ ] to put
Baltimore away cuz nothing what she's
doing makes any [ __ ] sense one of the
reports was she got stoned and somebody
was following her that's even creepier
she got stoned and drove around
aimlessly yeah for hours she ended up at
a Home Depot buying pink lightbulbs
all right so she got that going for get
off her back Tara Reid by the way also
competing for the title this week she
was in San Tropez France she was walking
down the street loaded and fell into a
motorcycle this was the end result yeah
that's oh that's her after the
motorcycle won the fight my favorite
thing was she tweeted on Monday
TMZ are liars they're always against me
they pushed us down that's why we fell
it's a setup
she didn't add up they pushed a gallon
of vodka down my throat before politics
and show business crossing paths again
this week Larry Flynt hustler magazine
publisher has offered a 1 million dollar
bounty to anybody who can come up with
Mitt Romney's tax returns because he
famously won't release them like Larry
Flynt he always makes life interesting
[Music]
tune in next week surfer creepy clown
Larry Flynt Alison Pill from the
newsroom she had a rough week I don't if
you guys are watching the newsroom or
not the Aaron Sorkin show on HBO she
plays maggie on that show she
accidentally tweeted a topless photo of
herself this week I never want to do
this she said my tech issues are now
reached to new heights apparently how a
deletion turned into a tweet I don't
know apologies she tweeted she deleted
it immediately which means it's all over
the Internet yeah here's the shot in
case you were curious what she looks
like topless
we're together what I want to know is
what are your glasses doing on her face
that's what I want to know where did she
get those glasses what's going on was
she perhaps in the meeting room at
Comikaze no I think she's engaged she is
yeah apparently she was sending him that
that picture when all things went
haywire Wow yeah bad stuff well I mean
she got a good sense of humor about it
and apparently because they say that she
was in New York this week for Fashion
Week
and she was found falling down drunk on
the streets of New York according to the
New York Post yelling about other
people's flatulence really just like Fox
Valley man yeah exactly
yeah she fall into a motorcycle no
luckily she didn't Kim Kardashian in the
news this way I'm sorry
porn star Kim Kardashian
[Music]
Kim Kardashian was talking about what
she learned from her 72 day marriage to
Kris Humphries yes you should take some
advice from porn star Kim Carlotta hear
how she makes it last
she said the decision to get a divorce
was a difficult one but something that
she learned from let me give you the
quote I think that with any decision in
life like I spoke to a girl today who
had cancer and we were talking about how
hard it is for her but it taught her a
big lesson on who her friends are and we
are so much alike she's 18 and I was
like yeah that's how I feel marriage is
a cancer so her divorce is the same
thing as being 18 year old and we have
cancer yeah that's good stuff Wow movie
news Nick Nolte the movie star is 71
years old and he has a five-year-old
daughter named Sophie
I know nick nolte is batshit crazy and
he's a 71 year old with a 5 year old
daughter and I thought I was I was
starting late in life but he's got a
five year old he they say he's a great
dad though this week he was caught at
the Malibu Kiwanis chili cook-off with
his daughter Sophie who's five years old
and she wanted to go on the bumper cars
and so Nick took her on the bumper cars
71 year old Nick took her on the bumper
cars I think we have a picture featuring
them yeah it's just before he clutched
his chest and fell over backwards we're
not friends and we're not neighbors
Nicolas Cage making movies of Vanessa
Hudgens called the frozen ground
according to sources on the set Vanessa
had to go to producers and ask them to
keep Nick from following her around
yeah apparently he was creeping around
he would watch her constantly and show
up on the set when he wasn't filming
just to watch her work she had to ask
producers to keep him away because it
was affecting her performance stop it
really do you think he's just a massive
High School Musical fan she plays a
stripper in the movie if that means
anything I'll just be over here a while
back stripper protector my hand in my
pants let's take a look at the geek news
shall we Kevin I pick
[Music]
Green Lantern got married this week I
heard man Hal Jordan married Carol
Ferris it had finally happened finally
happened Ryan Reynolds who played Green
Lantern in that god-awful movie Mary's
Lake good-looking people had kind of
chance to have sex with each other
that's rare though throw some more good
good-looking people under the world he
was previously married to Scarlett
Johansson now he's married to Blake
Lively did they marry yes yeah they were
married they were married for two years
this guy gets around chicks love this
[ __ ] dude you do dream of
consciousness just kind of working
through it in my head I didn't know the
booze they got married at some place
called Boone Hall Plantation in South
Carolina
apparently the slaves worked the events
though they still have in South Carolina
oh yeah it's a plantation Florence Welch
of Florence and the Machine where that
was the wedding singer she's saying she
entertained it's nice that money isn't
Italy right yeah
President Obama jumped out of a cake
that's [ __ ] money when you can pay
Barack to just come out in pasties his
mask man that Green Lantern mask that
was where it all kind of went wrong yeah
like when you think about I still think
about that trail the first time they
showed him the focus from his eyes just
always looked weird he looked like a
living cartoon character but not in a
good way if only they just made them all
white like a Little Orphan Annie or
something like that or just let his eyes
alone just whatever nah [ __ ] that just
all white man they're remaking Godzilla
Warner Brothers has announced Godzilla
yes now listen before we get too excited
remember the Matthew Broderick Godzilla
let's not get too excited it ain't gonna
be that they're going traditional I know
some people are like why can't Hollywood
come up with a new idea I agree with you
but at the same time I want to see a new
guy I do too
it's gonna be 3d and they say they're
going back over mine they're going
to the root of Godzilla which means
which meets a lot of screaming Japanese
people they're gonna blame the US again
for nuclear testing under seas and it's
gonna open up a chasm where guys a
little bit sleeping and he's gonna wake
up and have nuclear breath or whatever
he had and shit's gonna happen so I get
I just want to see him breaking [ __ ]
that's it
that'll work man because like in the
Avengers everyone went crazy when fog
and [ __ ] Hulk smash and he just took
buildings down and [ __ ] so they're like
lizard noggin [ __ ] down and breathing
and then everyone's want someone
screaming and running see ya I like a
man who can pick a cue here's my fear
someone's gonna write it next week
Godzilla creepy clown that's only the
show you have no JJ Abrams is working on
his sequel to the 2009 Star Trek reboot
movie this week they announced the title
star trek into darkness
what a [ __ ] horrible title that is
wait hold on Star Trek and Star Trek :
know that the thing
my space you're I'm sorry I got very
excited because they made an important
point early on when they were thinking
of a title for this that Damon Lindelof
one of JJ Abrams lackeys said publicly
to the press
we're not gonna have any Colin snow
Cohen's because that's been the the the
the standard forever we're changing that
no Cowen's no Colin's so no Colin's
whether you're so it's star trek into
darkness
so Star Trek is a verb and a noun in
that in their star trek into darkness
yes so instead of having a colon it's
how it came out of a colon that's that
[Music]
so get used to it
start trek into darkness I don't care
they could call it Star Trek suck my
dick it's gonna be amazing
it will be awesome I believe there's
some fanfiction featuring Kirk and Spock
that has that title already and while
we're talking about geeks the moment all
nerds everywere was I apologize I
sobered up for a moment
God take to roll sound picture speed and
action the moment all nerds have been
waiting for Emma Watson's nipple slip
finally happened this week Emma Watson
Hermione of course from the Harry Potter
films she was on the red carpet of her
new movie The Perks of Being a
Wallflower and she was wearing a very
very skimpy dress the 22 year old once
and here's a shot of her on the red
carpet let me bring out my laser pointer
I can look this is Hermione look right
there right there Kevin we've got nipple
we have nipple or so I thought it's more
areola than anything else it is but
let's take a closer look let's zoom in a
little bit shall we look look at that
it's some sort of magical nipple shield
she has on that Jeep she came up with a
spell to protect your own nipples yes a
binding spell if you will yes so I
thought we were getting nipple but over
getting is is plastic I think that's the
lady's anybody out there I know what
that is hey season what does it meant to
do hold on one person go ahead so they
don't stick out oh so if she gets hard
nipples that just she's keeping them
down let your nipples run free ladies
imprisoning your nipples and [ __ ]
when I get a boner I just let it rise
yeah you don't wear a boner shield
totally man I'm like boner kiss and it
just happens and [ __ ] but more of a
nipple protector every week we have to
ask a question in the form of music
[Music]
quick reset it's all happening cuz
Kevin's obsessed with the size of Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] and ru and as the sweet so
we asked the question in the form of a
inform of a website Neeson's [ __ ] calm
you can go to and add your own facts
about or parables as they say in the
Swedish newspaper about the size of
Liam's [ __ ] here are this week's Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big wails go Liam's
[ __ ] watching
[Laughter]
seem just outside w-wait Lisa's [ __ ] is
so big that Chuck Norris's white fears
his erection will plunge us into a
thousand years of darkness Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big inky pinky blinky and
Clyde turned blue and run away whenever
they see it goes Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big
atheists refused to acknowledge its
existence good work Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big that when he unzips his pants
in taken two it'll be the biggest
opening and movie history Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big the only way he can lose
his erection is by removing the head or
destroying the brain I repeat by
removing the head or destroying the
brain Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that
he walks used it to knock down an
imperial walker
it is like him and Michael Fassbender
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that it
still refuses to release its past income
tax returns and lastly Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big it took an eight-year
break and still protected Gotham City
from crime thank you so much for joining
us again for a sold-out night we really
appreciate it enjoy
Batman live on the 27th we'll see next
week man we're not gonna be here but
we'll be at the candy Club and Agoura
Hills so come watch if you're venturing
deep in the valley come join us yeah and
then we'll be back here the next week as
per usual because this is our home and
we love you guys so much thank you for
selling us out for the last four [ __ ]
weeks change them up you guys Rock it's
fun for us to do thanks for being here
all the time man that is Hollywood
babble-on for this week I'm Kevin Smith
I'm round trying to have all the [ __ ]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen give it up for
Kevin Smith round robin
[Applause]
you